sylvie magne bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans la matinale d'air france
on le disait le ministre de l'éducation
a précisé les grandes lignes du
protocole sanitaire pour la rentrée il
est identique à peu près 1 celui de juin
dernier avec en plus un accès facilité à
la vaccination dans quel état d'esprit
vous êtes vous pour préparer cette
rentrée ce que vous avez des inquiétudes
évidemment comme nos collègues
enseignants
les infirmières d'éducation nationale
ont des inquiétudes fortes d'abord on
partage le snics-fsu lui aussi se désole
que
la nouvelle circulaire
sanitaire soit le journal du dimanche et
qu'on apprenne dans la presse les le
niveau de protocole et une partie des
mesures qui vont se mettre en oeuvre
avant même le dialogue social puisque le
prochain vrai point sanitaire
après ce 8 juillet est prévue mercredi
donc une fois de plus c'est voilà
le dialogue social est mis de côté pour
un tour des annonces nous aussi on a
besoin de précision du pratico pratique
parce que la wii peut se féliciter qui
est pas de passes sanitaire et que les
et là je puisse avoir accès à l'école
parce que évidemment l'objectif c'est
qu'ils soient devant les professeurs
pour pouvoir réussir scolairement pour
autant on a absolument aucune
information sur la manière dont les
choses vont pouvoir se passer je
on voit un petit peu ce qui s'est fait
au niveau de la réunion qui a déjà
repris on voit bien qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de choses qui sont affinés et
au niveau de d affirmer la de
l'éducation nationale on est surtout
préoccupé par effectivement comment les
choses vont s'organiser alors
voilà on va y revenir sur cette question
notamment de la validation vous évoquez
un pas deux passes sanitaire vous le
disiez pour les élèves ni pour les les
enseignants a précisé jean mi c'est le
blanc caire qu'est ce que vous en pensez
en tant qu'infirmière notamment pour les
enseignants est ce que on aurait pu
penser à un pass annie terre pour eux
comme ce qui se fait en italie
écoutez je vais pas me prononcer pour
les collègues enseignants je pense que
ils sont assez responsables et une
grande partie d'entre eux sont vaccinés
après le passage du ter gv une fille on
respecte les gestes barrières qu'on
porte le masque correctement je pense
que dans un premier temps il ne s'agit
pas de remettre de contraintes
supplémentaires ni pour les pollens ni
pour les personnels de l'éducation
nationale qui ont déjà beaucoup donné
depuis un an et demi pour le styx en
tout cas l'éducation est préférable à la
contrainte et peut-être faut-il
effectivement être plus incitatif que
contraignent en tout cas alors voir
parler de la question de la vaccination
vous l'aborder à l'instant que vous avez
des précisions concernant cette
possibilité pour les élèves de se faire
vacciner alors on parle de
pouvoir se faire vacciner dans l'école
mais aussi à l'extérieur est ce que vous
savez comment ça va se passer qui va
gérer tout cela finalement
pas du tout pour l'instant c'est
vraiment le grand flou et c'est ça qui
est très préoccupant pour nous parce
qu'on a bien vu avec les campagnes de
tests et d'autotest la manière dont
c'était géré ça détourne est souvent les
infirmières de leur première mission qui
est l'accueil des effets maintenant non
pas qu'on ne veuille pas participer à
l'effort national parce qu'on y
participe largement en étant au plus
proche des jeunes et en prenant en
charge une partie des conséquences de
cette pandémie en termes de mal être et
de besoins renforcer d'accompagnement
pour les jeunes et si on devait
maintenant en plus
de la participation au contact racing
aux hôtes hôtesse à la formation aux
autos testé à tout un tas d'autres
choses qui nous incombe si on doit en
plus participer à la vaccination c'est
très très préoccupant parce qu'on ne
peut pas continuer à laisser les
infirmeries fermés et des élèves sans
réponse à leurs besoins la consultation
infirmière elle doit être maintenu alors
on nous parle d' équipes mobiles mais
qui constituera ses équipes mobiles si
c'est un nouveau en partie des
infirmières volontaires ça veut dire que
pendant qu'elles souffrent ça ils ne
seront pas dans leur infirmerie parce
qu'il n'y a eu aucune création postes
pour faire face à la charge de travail
supplémentaire liée à la pandémie on
nous parle aussi de déplacement vers des
centres de vaccination y en a pas
forcément partout et puis comment ça va
s'organiser
les élèves ont besoin d'être en cours
face à leurs professeurs les
l'enseignement a été tellement dégradée
depuis un an et demi que ça ne peut pas
continuer et on a effectivement aucune
précision là dessus je pense que comme
pour les tests et les autotests ce sera
dès ce seront des décisions rectorales
en lien avec les ars et le préfet mais
je me connectais encore ce matin sur sur
la boîte academy on n'en sait pas plus
que ce qui a été écrit il ya dans la
presse ou ce qu'on a pu entendre dire
dans les médias juste pour conclure une
dernière question vous parliez des
autotests effectivement en mai dernier
jean michel blanquer avait prévu deux
auto test par semaine pour le personnel
et un pour les lycéens en quelques mots
ça a marché ou pas
alors pour les personnels c'était sur la
base du volontariat donc
on n'a pas vraiment de chiffres et de
retour sur le nombre de total qui ont pu
être distribués pour les élèves ça a été
assez compliqué à organiser
tous les élèves n'ont pas pu en avoir de
façon systématique un par semaine parce
que ce qui était en
semi présentiel et distant ciel n'était
pas là tout le temps avec la même
périodicité donc ça a été compliqué on
peut espérer que les élèves qui ont été
formés après un petit rappel puisse
continuer à en faire et peut-être aller
faire plus tôt chez eux car empiéter sur
lui tant de court parce que il n'ya pas
toujours de temps pendant lequel de
temps où ils n'ont pas cours pendant
lequel on peut le réaliser en tout cas
vraiment nous on souhaite enfin il va
être important en cette rentrée de
recentrer la prévention de rappeler les
gestes barrière parce qu'on a vu qu'en
fin d'année scolaire dernière il y avait
pas mal de relâchement et de rappeler
l'un d'agir aussi sur l'importance de se
protéger de protéger les autres et de
rappeler aux élèves et de leur faire de
la pédagogie sur la vaccination si on
veut vraiment parvenir à quelque chose
et les infirmières de l'éducation
nationale en termes d'éducation à la
santé sont un volet important et puis il
faudra aussi qu'on puisse enfin le temps
de répondre à leurs questions de
répondre aux inquiétudes des familles
quant à
toutes les démarches qu'elle pourrait
avoir à faire les la bonne compréhension
des consignes des ars ou des cpam et on
est fortement sollicitée par les
familles à ce propos la donc voilà il
faut qu'on puisse se recentrer sur nos
missions et faire de l'éducation à la
santé est aussi continuer à apprendre
charge les élèves qui ne vont pas bien
c'est vraiment aussi important que de
les envoyer en cours parce que pour
réussir scolairement il faut pouvoir
être disponible et allait bien pour y
arriver merci beaucoup silvio mind
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france je le rappelle vous
êtes infirmières scolaires secrétaire
général adjoint du snuipp fsu